this is what my last week looked like
what I did who I was with the main
sensations I had for every waking hour
if the feeling came as I thought of my
dad who recently passed away or if I
could have just definitely avoided the
worries and anxieties and if you think
I'm a little obsessive you're probably
right but clearly from this
visualization you can learn much more
about me than from this other one which
are images you're probably more familiar
with and you should possibly even have
on your phone right now bar charts for
the steps to walk pie charts for the
quality of your sleep the path of your
morning runs in my day job I work with
data
I run a data visualization design
company and we design and develop ways
to make information accessible through
visual representations and what my job
is taught me over the years is that to
really understand data and there to
potential
sometimes we actually have to forget
about them and see through them instead
because they are always just a tool we
use to represent reality they're always
just a placeholder for something else
but they are never the real thing but
let me step back for a moment when I
first understood this personally in 1994
I was 13 years old I was a teenager in
Italy I was too young to be interested
in politics but I knew their businessman
Silvio Berlusconi was running for
president for the moderate right we
lived in a very liberal town and my
father was a politician for the
Democratic Party and I remember that no
one saw the Berlusconi could get elected
that was totally not an option but it
happens and I remember the feeling very
vividly it was a complete surprise as my
dad promised that in my town he knew
nobody who voted for him this was the
first time when the
I had give me a completely distorted
image of reality my data sample was
actually pretty limited and skewed so
probably was because of that I saw I
lived in a bubble and it didn't have
enough chances to see outside of it now
fast forward to November 8 2016 in the
United States the internet called
statistical models all the pundits
agreeing on a possible outcome for the
presidential election it looked like we
had enough information this time and
many more chances to see excite a close
circle we lived in but we clearly didn't
the ceilings
felt very familiar I had been there
before I think it's fair to say that
data failed us this time and pretty
spectacularly we believed in data but
what happened even with the most
respected newspaper is that the
obsession to reduce everything to choose
simple percentage numbers to make a
powerful headline made us focus on these
two digits and them alone in an effort
to simplify the message it draw a
beautiful inevitable red and blue map we
lost the point completely we somehow
forgot that there were stories stories
of human being behind these numbers on a
different context but to a very similar
point at the Collier challenge is
presented to my team by this woman she
came to us with a lot of data but
ultimately she wanted to tell one of the
most humane stories possible she is
Samantha Christopher yes [ __ ] she has
been the first Italian woman astronaut
and she contacted us before being lunch
on a six-month long expedition to the
International Space Station
she told us I'm going to space and I
want to do something meaningful with the
date of my mission to reach out to
people a mission to the International
Space Station comes with terabytes of
data how about anything you can possibly
imagine the orbits around Earth the
speed and position of the ISS and all
the other thousands live streams from
its sensors we had all of the hard data
we could think of just like the Columbus
before the election but what is the
point of all these numbers people are
not interested in data for the
sake of it because numbers are never the
point they're always the means to an end
the story we needed to tell is that
there is a human being in a team box
flying you space above your head and if
you can actually see her with your naked
eye in a clear night so we decided to
use data to create a connection between
Samantha and all of the people looking
at her from below we designed and
developed what we called friends in
space a web application that simply like
to say hello to Samantha from where you
are and in low to hold the people where
online at the same time from all over
the world and all of these hellos left
visible mark on the map as Samantha was
flying by and as she was actually waving
back everyday at us using Twitter from
the ISS if these made people see the
missions data from a very different
perspective it all suddenly became much
more about our human nature and our
curiosity relevant technologies so data
power the experience but stories of
human beings were the drive the very
positive response of its thousands of
users taught me a very important lesson
that working with data means designing
ways to transform the abstract in the
uncountable into something that can be
seeing felt indirectly connected to our
wives and to our behaviors something
that is hard to achieve if we let the
obsession for the numbers in the
technology around them lead us in the
process but we can do even more to
connect data to the stories that
represent we can remove technology
completely a few years ago I met this
other woman
Stephanie Pacific a london-based
designer who shares with me the passion
and obsession about data we didn't know
each other but we decided to run a very
radical experiment starting a
communication using only data no other
language and we opted for using no
technology whatsoever to share our data
in fact our only means of communication
will be through the old-fashioned post
office for the Avera every weekend for
one year we use our personal data
to know each other personal data around
weekly shared mundane topics from our
feelings to the interaction level
partners from the complimentary received
to the sounds of our surroundings
personal information that we will then
manually hand roll on a postcard sized
sheet of paper then we would every week
send from London to New York where I
live and from New York to London where
she leaves where the front of the Coast
Guard is the data drawing and the back
of the card contains the address of the
other person of course and the legend
how to interpret our drawing the very
first week into the project we actually
chose a pretty cold and impersonal topic
how many times do we check the time in a
week so here is the front of my card and
you can see that every little symbol
represents all the times that I check
the time position for days and different
hours chronologically nothing really
complicated here but then you see in the
legend how I added anecdotal videos
about these moments in fact the
different types of symbols indicate why
I was checking the time what was they
doing was I bored was i hungry was like
late do they check it on purpose or just
casually glance at the clock and this is
the key part representing the details of
my days and my personalities through my
data collection using data as a lens or
a filter to discover and reveal for
example my never-ending anxiety for
being late even though I'm absolutely
always on time Stephanie and I spent one
year collecting our data manually to
force us to focus on the new ones is
that computer cannot gather or at least
not yet
using data also to explore our minds in
the words we use and not only our
activities like it with number three
where we track the thank-yous we said
and we received and when I realized that
I thank most of the people that I don't
know apparently I'm a compulsive center
to waitresses and waiters but I
definitely don't thinking of the people
were close to me over one year the
process of actively no decedent
counting these types of actions became a
ritual and actually changed ourselves we
became much more in tune with ourselves
much more aware of our behaviors and our
surroundings over one year Stephanie and
I connected at a very deep level through
our shared data diary who we could do
this only because we put ourself in
these numbers adding the context of our
very personal stories to them it was the
only way to make them truly meaningful
and representative of ourselves I am NOT
asking you to start drawing your
personal data or to find a pencil across
the ocean but I'm asking you to consider
data all kind of data at the beginning
of the conversation and not the end
because data alone will never give us a
solution and this is why they distilled
us so badly because we failed to include
the right amount of context to represent
reality in nuanced complicated and
intricate reality we kept looking at
these two numbers obsessing with them
and pretending the our world could be
reduced to a couple of digits and a
horserace well the real story is the one
that really mattered were somewhere else
what we missed
looking at these stories only through
models and algorithms is what I call
data humanism in the Renaissance
humanism European intellectual place the
human nature instead of God as the
center of the view of the world I
believe something similar needs to
happen with the universe of data now
data are apparently treated like a god
keeper of infallible tools for our
present and our future the experiences
that I shared with you today taught me
that to make data faithfully
representative of our human nature and
to make sure they will not mislead us
any more we need to start designing ways
to include empathy imperfection and
human qualities in how we collect
process analyze and display them I do
see a place where ultimately instead of
using data only to become more efficient
we will all use data to become more
humane thank you
Oh
[Applause]